so i i was looking at doge and
it hit 70 cents i know
which is well who cares yeah whatever i
know it's
i care it's bad well
i mean do you really think that it's a
good thing that
one person can create something that
like i mean
maybe it's a good thing i don't know but
like i think it's actually a bad sign in
terms of how
stable and reliable our markets are that
like one person can
make something that now trumps the
market cap of what
it's bigger than like car companies it's
bigger than moderna
now well that's where i feel with doge
and it's a meme yeah i know people are
like oh my god it's beautiful that
that something like this was able to
skyrocket
and create wealth and all this stuff i
agree but it's like i think it's also
a sign of like massive volatility and
that's probably bad
yeah my thought was everyone who's been
mining
doge from like six years ago assuming
those people still held on
which they probably some probably did i
feel like when those guys hit the lever
everyone else is gonna be stuck holding
the bag like someone is
yeah someone is that's the crazy part is
how many
these the amount of people now it'll be
interesting to hear this
when this episode goes up to see where
doge is at yeah that's true as it
at this point um i've seen everyone and
anyone tweet about
uh doge even benny the butcher he's
tweeted about doge twice
okay it's not a guy who uses twitter
that often right you know he comes on
and says like some vague like you know
drug dealer tweet and then for him to
just get on and be like
it's doge for me i'm like oh no
oh no literally everyone's everyone
everyone's bought it oh yeah you know so
and elon is on snl tonight so it could
pop
like we could see a dollar today yeah
who knows
yeah so it in in spirit of this
it kind of hit me where i go i know i
mind doge but
i wanna i i wonder where that was at
and so i started thinking like
uh maybe i have like an old email or
like some reference to an
old wallet so i go through one of my old
emails and uh
i find it a confirmation email i find
two things
one uh a
connection script for cgminer and i go
oh yeah
i was like part of that pool so i dig up
the email for my
the mining pool i was in which was team
doge uh
so i go to their website and it's like
that generic
you know that landing page that hosts
put up with like
related searches okay so like i go to
that site and it redirects me it's like
dogecoin does crypto it's like you know
malware basically like all right so this
doesn't exist anymore
and uh so i go to their twitter
they haven't tweeted since 2015 and they
tweeted
like a couple days ago and they go
the dream of doge hitting a dollar is
finally around the corner there's four
replies and one guy goes
yeah man i just cracked open my old
wallet and i see i have 16
000 doge i'm waiting for you guys to
confirm so
then i realized that the doge i had
mined i never
took out of the pool so i started
racking my brain and i started thinking
and i legitimately think i mined like a
couple hundred thousand dose
couple hundred thousand dollars no way
yeah because at that point the
difficulty was absurdly low
and my miners were like really juiced up
like uh
the most they could be for graphics
cards yeah and
i remember when doge first came up me
and
so i had three minors my co-worker had
like
five or six i mean we were glaine had
galen had a bunch it's so many and she
just couldn't keep her hands off them
and she's always just tinkering with
these
oh god okay tinkering sorry sorry
too much no too much now yeah
and so uh
sorry i'm just thinking about glenn and
her absurd crypto
you know all the time she'd be like no
well let's get more reminders i'm like
glenn you have enough yeah
chill out anyway so
i remember the bitcoin difficulty was
sort of annoying
and so we pivoted to litecoin and then
we all agreed like we should mine some
[ __ ] coins
to whatever doge at that point i think
was worth like
it was like to the 16th or 20th decimal
place right
and uh so i'm pretty sure like a couple
hundred thousand
couple hundred thousand right i
distinctly remember
hitting like a hundred and some thousand
like within like
a couple hours and thinking holy [ __ ]
and i have this one quote that's
burning in my head of one of my
co-workers he's laughing going
i love this doggy coin man i'm mining it
and i literally have
millions and millions and millions of it
i'm like
i'm thinking about him now just
he can't remember his password either
he's like
no him and one of my other buddies
held on they they've held on since
since 2014. yeah okay so obviously that
that is cool like obviously that's
[ __ ] cool if you
yeah mine something you take a chance of
something right at the beginning and
then all of a sudden that
turn like just by a stroke of luck turns
into millions of dollars that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah and that's something that
crypto
allows for right now i think crypto is
still the most the
the most amount of like asymmetric
opportunities but i think that it's
getting
absurd like the amount of people that
have hit me up to pump
these [ __ ] [ __ ] coins and the amount
of people that i see
doing it on twitter like just hey um
don't forget to to mine uh you know like
[ __ ] dick coin
yeah safe come right or like catch up
ball coin
yeah or come rocket this one actually
seems like a little bit legit actually
but there's
like anything okay so you're bought in
yeah so yeah yeah so guys i actually
think come rocket is a
it's a very a very solid investment
man you've got equity in this yeah you
gotta um
but i think the amount of people i see
like there's so many
pump and dumps there's the fact that
elon can tweet something
and doge rockets up 30 is ultimately a
very bad thing if one person can
control a market like that it's just
gonna end up in in
normal people holding the bag yeah like
you know it's like our [ __ ] aunts and
uncles are going to see a tweet
safe doge moon ball coin yeah yeah and
they're going to invest
their like pension into that yeah and
it's going to just tank in two weeks
and they're going to you know what i'm
saying and some guy with a samurai sword
and
millions and millions in crypto living
in monaco because you guys want to pay
taxes yeah
it's going to be like yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah i knew i knew hentai coin was a
good idea
i knew austin creamer hentai was a good
[Laughter]
you know you know uh cardano
yeah my my buddy bought into that
at the time of these balls yeah i don't
know there's something there exciting
there is on oh these balls are in your
mouth
oh hey grant greg
you're getting cardona oh i wish your
balls were in my mouth
i mean opposite i mean the opposite
[Laughter]
i was just thinking of trying to play oh
man i got four brain cells
grand car dunk
crash don't stop putting your balls in
my mouth right the other way
why do i keep damn
krypto got you feeling some kind of way
you're here to hear first it's just all
these this talk about ball coin
yeah but yeah nut coins sweaty tanks
swastika yeah yeah you get your swast
coin
have you guys ever heard of swamp ass
coin
yeah it's a it's a it's a type of crypto
used specifically to buy adult diapers
to counteract gooch sweat and
[ __ ] your own pants i think it's
next up man you guys should invest
seriously definitely pump this [ __ ]
we're going to the moon look at this
tick tocker launches scam coin raises 70
million an hour after launch this is
like this stuff should not be happening
shouldn't be happening yeah i mean it's
just crazy like
i i know that crypto can't really be
regulated
but it just makes me think stuff like
this will
trigger someone to try to regulate it it
may not ever work
but i feel someone will try definitely
absolutely
and why is money even real you know yeah
why do we even
if you think about it yeah money is
actually
a social construct actually it's all
fiat man yeah
fiat more like fake
fake money isn't real
wake up you sheeple money is [ __ ]
subjective so
absolutely fake yeah so those are
those are our hot takes on crypto right
now guys and it might be completely
different by the time this comes out
maybe it's
the whole thing is collapsed maybe maybe
doge is
ten thousand dollars by this point those
things aren't that far-fetched that's
the problem with this whole thing
yeah it's so what is the come rocket one
go back to that that was to
well i actually have the white paper
memorized so
kryptos hottest new nsfw currency
spearheaded by a young female software
engineer you know how you know how you
mine this one
that's actually what the the [ __ ] it's
for the [ __ ] no no the come
uh fridge is four that we were gonna get
yeah yeah yeah
the summons and then you
rock it come into it and the velocity
yeah
the velocity that you rocket your come
out into that thing they harness that
energy and they use that to mine
come rock it it's just kind of like a
gas tank you just got to fill it up and
it keeps mining
right yeah
i'm rich i'm rich i'm rich it's
it's as many times as you can come
that's how much money you can make
all right what is this crypto's hottest
new nsfw currency
no no the to provide an nft marketplace
for 18 plus content yeah i mean that
makes sense
i'm surprised that it hasn't already
been a thing how is how is porn behind
the curve
yeah with nfts that's bizarre actually
yeah that's a paradigm shift right there
yeah that sex isn't
at the front because porn has been
leading innovation forever
no seriously they've always had like
they're the first to do like
scrubbing in a video i'm pretty sure i
think morning video porn invented that
video uh thumbnails thumbnails yep i i
love that tweet
i always love remembering that tweet
when pornhub was like hey youtube nice
feature where'd you get that
um senior engineer comes into work one
day
wiping his hands yes so i had an idea
last night
why don't we preview the video guys i
just had a crazy idea in the bathroom
i'm kind of tired so you can talk about
it tomorrow but
i think it's going to change the way we
do things here we should do video
thumbnails that's a great idea dude high
five
i'm gonna wash my hands that's so
foul you came in your hands at work and
you went
to go tell people that's a true creative
right there
i must tell everyone
quick give me your face simba
and you are the engineer going to
implement this for me
[Laughter]
right across the forum
[ __ ] dude
you